hey guys before this be log I should let
you know that there has been a little
bit of a goof up on the DVD that I got
apparently doesn't necessarily have the
episodes in order and some are missing
but it's weird how not in order they are
like apparently gem glow it's like the
first episode but it's the one where he
gets like the cat ice cream things or
something like that it's like but that's
the second episode on the disc so while
they have that is the first really weird
so most people are saying you don't need
to see them in order for the first
season but we like to so what we did is
that we already shot four we did a laser
light cannon which is technically the
last one this one I think is gem glow
the ones after that hold on uh bubble
buddies and ours you know and cat
fingers uh those are the four we've done
so far
after that tell the DVD and having them
so strangely out of order oh we're just
gonna go to Amazon and watch them there
cuz they have them in order there
I hope I'm pretty sure they do so uh for
these next three episodes that's what
it's gonna be it's going to be those
from what I hear you don't necessarily
have to see them in order and they kind
of started the middle the story still
regardless so yeah just know that
they're the rest after this next three
are going to be in order except for the
ones that we're a jump to have a you
know what I mean so yeah sorry about
that our opinions are still our real
opinions uh be good to each other we're
back and we have the combination one two
three four five got Mike homework on
your putz
um this is episode two Jim glow um by
God do I want an ice cream sandwiches I
don't know buddies goddamn business how
in the shape of a fucking Ken but if you
have strawberry vanilla so help me God
yeah that's uh if somebody hasn't made
bad a tree yet it like Soledad Kahn what
are you waiting for yeah do it Rihanna's
say they can't beep I would think they'd
be that difficult to me let me
I'll bet you no you know what I'll bet
you somewhere the people at the cons who
make like the jewelry in the shape of
sushi and candy and okay there's got to
be somebody doing cookie cam out there
there has to be there's got to be
multiple people actually so uh so Steve
on the same subject they mentioned the
the lion boos like lion bars or
something and I am licking some lion
look of death it's like it doesn't even
have the face of a lion did you flash
back to when you were a kid and there
was like ice was like almost a Mickey
Mouse like sort of Sam oh I remember
that yeah and like that it's my favorite
it's true the face would always be
melting I'd always look like a sad
Mickey eryone oh yeah the Mickey's
usually melted to a frowny face but the
other ones I think they're talking about
are the Ninja Turtles ones cuz over
there was the turtle ones - yeah those
has more power - it had the Gumbel eyes
those are really melted it looked quite
disturbing because you would always buy
them in like the grocery store or
something and by the time you got them
home and everything you pulled about is
yeah I don't ask you for the ice cream a
like you just get him it's like this man
does not look like what's up the picture
man dude you know I've read it's been
sitting in your truck next to the two
severed heads for way too long
oh so yeah so cookie cat is going away
so Steven no one is ready sir yeah takes
the free sir would you like to take me
yo empathetic and the three women went
and bought on the well technically stole
but then compacted paid for which is
pretty funny the three women had means
yellow yeah that's why I thought
sesame easy don't be punchy fisty Oh
garnet amethyst and pearl asshole yeah
that's just because you remember the
open Oh sing today is this justice no he
actually uh no I came in right at the
opening he calls he was talking to them
individually and each time he said their
name right before well anyways I
remember I remember pearl because
and pearl like there's a pause before
it's I remember that one honestly I I
didn't hear it in the song because each
time we watch the so far I haven't seen
the intro
um to dis again something yeah well no I
needed ice too busy paying attention not
remembering their name I needed lunch so
I was getting that together and then the
second time I need water
oh I don't need to drink during this
it's fucked up a night I guess we drunk
um so he can know what this thing is if
you want to if you want to remember them
garnet is red amethyst is purple and
pearl is white just like the colors of
the gemstones ooh aren't we fancy pantsy
schmancy Dancy I used to collect rocks
as a kid yes hey Josh right hey that's
like I help me much time um but uh oh
yeah so he takes a bite of one of these
and his jewel works for the first time
it creates this shit
I I have to lie because like this is not
going to work out if because if the only
way to activate this kid's weapon is
seen an Ice Cream Sandwich inside a ham
shyaa'n
uh uh Oh wasn't gonna be yet oh I'm sure
it's like some form of like the pink
captain American shield that like the I
could shave off and destroys the
television I'm sure it's gonna be
something like you know you know some
form of like you know ease or content or
happiness or being laid back or
something like that
or satisfaction after good ice cream
sales but uh but they don't say what is
yeah what you can't like um but so he's
trying to figure out what what causes it
and the other women are telling him how
they go about I like how they all had
different ways and we're really
complicated so the girls is hard
amethyst is easy and then garnets is
like somewhere between yeah oh and I
like a like a my variation mill with all
of the elements of a matter of the earth
you know people that are really good at
pretty much anything uh you know usually
have a way of doing it that they're
either like it's either really
complicated and they kind of in the zone
or other people are like nothing's easy
I just do this uh so or something in
between I mean that I kind of like that
that there's no one whaling has to be
this one way in a sorry these variation
nobody came up with the correct answer
which is make someone else do it okay oh
oh so he thinks he knows how to do he
thinks it's the ice cream and then does
a giant centipede with an eye in its
mouth and jewels I was back
pretty cool actually it's my mother yeah
starts to attack him and he can't figure
out how to make it work is clearly not
the ice cream but still help them out so
they can defeat the monster and
eventually they say oh you know you'll
figure it out eventually and it ends
there um so I got like oh wait I just
say it's funny because this show is not
haha funny like gravity falls is haha
funny like really full of laughs but the
two or three laps it does have tucked in
the 15 minutes or pretty damn well what
I like about to them those they're um
they're all very likable yeah very
positive I may even like you know if
they're gonna make fun each other
something like that there's just that
they're all kind of supportive and funny
and they're kind of the parents you
always want I mean that's the thing it's
like I'm watching some like the shows
all - the title could have been steven
has three mommy yeah
like us the way they interact I'm like
okay they're clear they're clearly the
mother figures here there's three of
them which are you waving at a boy yeah
it's it's like full house or something
in Reverse yeah - yeah um but yeah I
mean they're they're really likable
though the jokes are very understated I
like like you sometimes you blink in you
miss him like I love was like so how did
you get all these ice cream sandwiches
well we uh stole them and they're like
grrrrrr and then pearls this yeah
amethyst is like well we kind of stole
them and then pearl jumps is like yeah
well I had to pay them back yeah and go
back and pay it to go back and pay
though ya know the uh like I said
there's something there's kinda like
this laid-back nature to it I like but
it does energize to focus enough to like
your interest the final note at the end
just like quick yeah you don't think
it's gonna fit
yeah you think it's a ten on this soft
touching gun instead he told me bars and
it was perfectly cut - knew right where
to cut yes well I like that you think
they're damocat this cornea hahaha like
most you know cartoons in the 80s did
invention animal yeah and then closing I
thought was really good um but is
something about this episode of kind of
like because I felt it sort of
introduced you know this element of
discovery your your power and how this
gem
works and how does it work in these
different explanations of a bed it felt
um I don't want say it felt real but at
the same time in the characters I know
put point a better words than I am a lot
of times you know in superhero stories
it feels like a constructed scene like
this is a big moment this is this feels
real because it's treated as just shit
happening like it's kind of treated
almost like he lost his first tooth or
something it's like look his gym started
warm oh yeah let's see if we can do so
it feels like a rarity job yes when I'm
like I'm on ok a little it's easy but
it's almost like baby's first steps it's
not like this big moment with giant
music like it somehow is just worked
into the plot in such a way that it
feels like a family moment and not like
yeah giant superhero like exposition
moment like you know we're only on
Episode two and I already feel like
these characters have much more of a
connection and a unity to each I feel
like a real family
yeah I see no me reason shows and stuff
like that um yeah it looks like how much
time were we invest into somewhere but
maybe like 24 minutes and 24 minutes
they managed to accomplish more than
half the films i watch every year yeah
uh and it's through very simple things
but I think part of it too is cuz nobody
has like all the answers is not all
explaining it's not all talking and it's
different points of view and like I said
that that's reality and that makes it
more relatable it's not one person has
the answer I mean no matter who you are
you're not going to put all your trust I
mean everything in one person or you
probably shouldn't you know not not free
get everything I mean there's gonna be
people that like you know are gonna make
you laugh more this people are gonna
make you think horror there's gonna be
behind there could be some word crud
there's gonna be people that encompass a
lot of that you know but nobody's gonna
have everything and nobody should have
everything and that's why I think a show
like this really works cuz in Sony shows
it's like the mage of the smart one just
like or this agent friggin knows
everything and explains everything and
should follows person then like maybe in
episode 22 you'll find out that there's
something they didn't know it here it
seems really balanced out that not
everybody has the
answered everything they're all kind of
discoveries together for the cooperative
teamwork going on yeah I like that a lot
um you know they both seem a really rely
are clearly Stephen doesn't know that
much about what he has or even been I
guess what he is uh but the other three
do know who they are what they have how
to use it but they're trying to learn
from they all named after specific
gemstones what the hell is his stone the
Steven stone I guess hey I was wondering
I was his mother named Rose that's nice
don't either
Wow yawn I mean you couldn't remember
their names but you remembered his
mother was named Rose what's like the
most generic name I've ever per la rose
and pearls oh very right outside of
indecent in this rock or whatever cool I
I didn't remember what her name was so
good I'll add to the list of me I feel
give me my dick where was I thought was
rose um we should just agree never to
read the comments yeah we'll just fuck
it up all the way
odds guy no I read like 1 or 2 or a fan
just get a general feel um but yeah it's
uh I liked it I like I said something
about it felt a little bit you see what
I mean about the the background our
thumb now right yeah no now they look
closer right account so yes Romney
there's a lot of color yeah yeah I mean
it's nothing it it's probably digital
but yeah but they're mimicking that look
which is really cool um yeah yeah and I
and I do like it and I like the island
or their secret headquarters or whatever
the fuck that is well that's something I
donated just even whether or not asleep
because he hasn't dad the the other two
episodes I saw I mean we saw the dad it
was like oh we haven't seen each other
in a long time he has a couple of
episodes I saw which is when I
recommended it to you and said you need
to see this show he was at that
headquarters like yeah like every
episode I've seen he's been at doing yes
a minute is Leah so I'm maybe he's just
like yeah raining with them like you
know they take away to train him but
they know he's dad's like right there so
I'm not entirely sure well I guess cuz
he does have a gemstone in his belly
they probably would know what to do and
I don't know I even had a bring me
mommies and lives in a giant statue
right by the sea who
hasn't had that upbringing come on who
has three mommies it tends to live lives
under the sea so yeah good episode we'll
see you in part 3 see you there